[Music]
thought and really good friend to the
channel has been able to tell me a
little bit about the Star Trek pitch for
Academy and it's a little bit what we
thought but actually a little bit good
welcome to SRA your Sci-Fi TV and Movie
Channel as you guys know if you're a
regular side treer we've been talking
about Star Trek Academy for a while we
keep calling it Star Trek 90210 poking
fun a little bit at the TV show that we
suspect is not really going to be for
older trekkies there is a bit of a
theory by Alex curtzman and his friends
over at secret hideout that they like to
create Star Trek shows for different
demographics Discovery was for a younger
audience and will put my hands up right
now and say I really don't like
Discovery I've tried I've really tried
I'm a trekky at heart so a new Star Trek
show comes out I want to love it but I
just don't I think it's full of
characters I don't care about and
basically I really never liked the
design of the ship that was really a
problem from day one for me the
characters is a little bit more of an
issue but but what I'm trying to say is
other than maybe season too which I
actually did like and every episode that
Empress Georgio has been in because
she's amazing I've not liked Discovery
so news that we're getting Star Trek
academy doesn't fill me with much
excitement either because talking to my
source he's been able to confirm that
yes this will be a follow on from
Discovery I think that's not really
breaking news we all know that it's been
hinted that several times in the show it
it can also confirm to me that the
moment the character Tilly from
Discovery will be appearing in this
series also again not really a shock but
he has been able to tell me a little bit
about what secret hideout pitched to
Paramount but more importantly what
Paramount then dictated back to secret
hideout about what they wanted in this
show they did give them a set of sort of
guidelines what this show is supposed to
look like and I'm going to be able to
tell you bit more about that now so for
one what secret hideout basically
pitched this show as was not just
Starfleet Academy and the actual
rebuilding of Starfleet but this show
would be a way of seeing the Federation
getting rebuilt as well Through The Eyes
of the youngest Cadets as they begin
their journey to boldly go where no one
has gone before now I'm actually going
to say that is a massive positive for me
because actually rebuilding the
Federation is something I kind of wanted
to see in Enterprise and we never did
get to see we missed a massive
opportunity there to see the Federation
actually
becoming but they focused on that
temporal time War thing instead a little
bit more than I'd have
liked here we have a fledgling rebuilt
Federation now obviously it's going to
be very different it's not what we
wanted to see in Enterprise but we get
to see some of those elements that we
should have seen in Enterprise maybe in
this new show now I quite like
procedural dramas and things I quite
like cop shows and stuff like that I
quite like shows that really get into
the detail of things if this show does
that a little bit and we get to see some
of the politics and stuff of rebuilding
the Federation an expansion of what
we've seen a little bit in the last
couple of seasons of um Discovery
actually to be fair then I'm all up for
that and I think that sounds like it
could be really interesting but let's be
honest they won't really do that they
will get locked into some overarching
story and you know that'll get ignored
but hey let's see one of the things they
did talk about was taking some of the
best things from Discovery for me and
expanding it into the new series of
Academy for example one of the things
they talked about apparently in the
pitch meetings is getting to see lots of
new Starships The Academy students will
get to spend time on different ships
doing different missions throughout the
seasons that will get us the opportunity
to explore brand new Federation
[Music]
Starships that's a flying
rainforest let's be honest they probably
saw how excited sort of fans got when we
saw the new Voyager or the NOG things
like this and they they want to expand
upon that they will make a big deal
about maybe a new Enterprise we'll get
to see lots of things like that during
this series and apparently in the pitch
meeting they made a big deal about that
if you are enjoying the video don't
forget to like subscribe with the Bell
notification all those things but also
go over to
patreon.com sidre that is where most of
our videos do Premiere first and you get
to see them without all the adverts for
a small fee that really helps out the
channel so yes according again to the
people from secret hideout this will be
a very character-driven show aimed at
the younger audience they want to carry
the audience that they've developed
through Discovery into this new show now
I have nothing against character-driven
TV shows you can argue the next
Generation on the whole was a character
driven TV show I love series like
Firefly which is very much a
character-driven TV show but going back
to my silly little joke about calling
this Star Trek
90210 that is a little bit of a problem
to me and there are alarm Bells
apparently Paramount did dictate to
secret hideout that they need to have
far more interesting characters that
they wanted secret Ido to look at
strange new worlds and the way the
character development has worked on that
show and to try to emulate that again I
think parac are very much aware that
some of the characters from discover
have been very well let's say
forgettable and again other than Empress
Georgio who was just
phenomenal a lot of the
characters no one cares about they're
not interesting even the lead character
you know Michael Burnham isn't a
particularly interesting character a
great actress I absolutely adore her as
an actress but she's just not written
very well and that is a big problem and
something Paramount have really
emphasized during these pitch meetings
and then development discussions that
the characters have to be more
interesting now the big part of that is
going to be casting again Anson Mount is
a brilliant actor and he really brings
Pike alive but there are several other
characters over at strange the worlds
who are just more interesting than any
of the characters on Discovery they are
going to have to make a big effort on
that area now talking about that because
of the character development a
character-led show if the characters are
interest in the show will work if
they're not it won't and what we're
going to end up getting is a show like
90210 where it's a bunch of younger
people and younger people's problems if
the characters are well written and
they're interesting and their casting is
right everybody will be able to relate
to those characters if they're not
there's going to be some older trekkies
that once again feel a little alienated
by the Star Trek Academy like we feel a
little bit alienated by Star Trek
Discovery another thing that was
discussed in the early pitch meetings
and development meetings was that
Discovery was not a particularly funny
series again other than the Georgio
episodes which were brilliant because
she was just such a a bigger than life
character Discovery was way more serious
and param very early on dictated that
they want to see a lot more humor in
this new series of Star Trek and
apparently during the pitch meetings
that was what was discussed a lot is
ways that this is going to have a little
bit more of an injection of humor in
every episode and that actually the way
Star Trek Academy is being set up it
will allow for that I suspect here and
this is just speculation but I suspect
here is going to be that there will be
certain characters that just can't get
anything right there will be funny
scenarios between different alien races
trying to get on and things like that I
can actually see lots of ways to inject
humor into a series like that even if it
is maybe a little bit slapstick whereas
you know they're trying to do something
they fail and let's be honest people
failing especially people that think
they're clever is always funny finally
the way Star Trek Academy was pitched
was saying that it wouldn't be a monster
of the week series or having major
overarching storylines that as I said
it's going to be very much character
driven and setting driven so it's driven
by the fact that they're in the academy
there will be the odd monster of the
week episode and there will be some
overarching storylines but the focus
will be on basically the classroom now I
don't know how you guys feel about that
get into the comments and tell me but I
think that's a little little bit
concerning from the
GetGo I think that really limits where
this show can go now I'm going to do a
video in a minute actually talking about
comparing Academy to Legacy and how I
feel Academy can harm the franchise but
Legacy could free it now the point is
that the setting is really important a
little bit like when Deep Space 9 came
out I didn't like it at first because I
felt it was set in a very limited way it
only really became an exciting TV show
when the defiant came into it because
that allowed the show to expand it freed
the
storytelling if you have a series that
is focused in one setting you are really
tying the hands of your writers because
they can't get out there and explore now
it seems that Academy has already
considered this because as I was saying
in the pitch meetings talking about
students go on different ships going in
on missions etc etc now that would allow
the series to be free to some degree but
not on a regular consistent basis so
that is a little bit concerning for me
another thing that is a little bit
concerning and I keep making this joke
that this is going to be Star Trek 90210
a joke that not all of you appreciate
but it does sort of represent my fees on
this I am going to say though really
quickly I am going to give Star Trek
Academy a chance when it comes out this
is a show that I've not seen this is a
show that's not even been completely
written yet so I'm not going to stand
here and say it's going to be a load of
rubbish I don't know what it's going to
be like but what I can do is talk about
my honest genuine fears about the show
they are my opinion and really if you
share those opinions get in the comments
if you don't get in the comments that's
the point of having a sort of discussion
like this on this channel no one's right
no one's wrong unless you say I'm wrong
in which case you'll be
banned not
really but things like the fact that the
showrunner is this Josh Schwartz is a
little bit concerning for me because
he's been the executive producer on lots
of TV shows over the years but those TV
shows are the kind of shows I'm worried
Star Trek Academy will
become it's things like the OC Gossip
Girl the astronaut Wives Club which was
actually a pretty good show but
it was also though the executive
producer on Chuck which was actually
quite a funny show and if we get
something a bit more like that and an
ejection of humor into that then yeah
that could work but shows like the OC
that really does fulfill all of my worst
fears if as a showrunner Josh Schwartz
brings those influences into this new
series we are going to get Star Trek
90210 and that is what I'm worried about
so this show has been decades in the
making it is true that actually Jean
rodeny even wanted to create a Star Trek
Academy show all those years ago we saw
Star Trek Academy episodes on TNG and
Deep Space 9 and I have to say on the
whole they were crap Wesley going off to
the academy and getting bullied I
couldn't care less they're the most
forgettable episodes they were
rubbish but in deep space
we got to see a Star Trek Academy
episode which was genuinely brilliant
Aaron eisenberger's nog was always one
of my favorite characters he was just
lovable and Brilliant we got to see a
different side of the frry in Deep Space
9 and nog was really the epitome of that
in the episode Valiant though he was
aboard the um defiant class Valiant that
was a training vessel it was a training
vessel that got caught Behind Enemy
Lines dur during the early first days of
the dominan war it had had a few
officers aboard that were killed early
on so all that was left now was red
Squad The Academy students the Elite
Academy students the best of the best
captained by Ramirez they actually had
this ridiculous plan to go after one of
the bigger Jem Hadar battle Cruisers and
they lost badly this episode did what
Deep Space 9 really did brilliantly a
few times which was flip what we
considered to be Star Trek on its head
this episode normally if it had been
Next Generation or something like that
would have had a happy ending the
Valiant would have survived the Valiant
maybe would have been saved by another
Starship or something and they'd have
all learned their lessons but they'd
have at least kept their lives in this
case that is not what happened it had a
very non-re ending and this was one of
those episodes that was actually written
by Ronald E Moore and you can tell
because it was very very clever and it
twisted all of our expectations now Star
Trek Academy can do episodes like that
something that does twist our
expectations and that does make us think
about those earlier days in our lives
when we were growing up then it could be
a great show but if they do episodes
like what we saw in
TNG then to be honest I don't want to
watch it but let's give it a chance
because this could actually go on to
become one of the great Star Trek shows
it does have lots of really interesting
possibilities and from the pitch
meetings there are things in there that
I really like the sound of but there's
also the problem that this is a TV
series it's potentially got one hand
tied behind its back and let's see what
the writers actually end up doing with
it it's going to be interesting though
either way so guys get into the comments
and tell me what you think is Star Trek
Academy Star Trek 902 or know something
you're excited about or actually do you
just think that's one obstacle in the
way of Legacy give us Legacy who gives a
crap about Academy that's a little bit
where I feel but I'm open to it being a
great show so let's cross our fingers
and hope but what do you think get into
the comments if you are new to the
Channel please like subscribe hit that
Bell notification it really helps us
there you'll never miss any of our new
videos also you can go to
patreon.com where most of our new videos
do appear first and you get to see them
without the adverts you lucky bunes also
go to
s.co which is our dedicated website and
we do articles based on most of our
videos and we try to addite a little bit
more information you to digest so go
check it out as always please stay safe
live long and prosper and I'll see you
next
time
[Music]